is a reality show something that you
guys would do I mean yeah definitely
something that would be super fun people
see what goes on when we're not just
posting which I feel like no one really
gets to see but people are always
talking about how they think our family
dynamics pretty cool like they love it
when we go live so that's super sighs I
mean it's really whatever folks like us
showcase what we're really like because
people really only see us like dancing
or listening to songs so it's great fun
maybe try some loop it it sounds like
that's something that's in the works is
that something you guys are actively
talking about yes oh my gosh this is so
exciting when do you think this could
happen and where would it live yes we're
figuring out a lot of stuff right now
we're kind of does this kind of happen
all really very quickly so well we think
it we're going to do it we might as well
go all in with it and really like
Charlie said just have everyone get to
know us a little bit more closely so
we're in the process working it out
right now for for mom and dad how do you
guys feel watching your daughters become
these massive celebrities it's been fun
it's a lot more positive than negative
which has been nice and just seeing the
whole thing happened so quickly I think
that was that's probably the craziest
part of it everything else we kind of
just taken stride unchartered waters but
we kind of just are rolling with it and
just keeping the number one thing close
to us as our family and our and being
there for each other
and that's the most important thing
making sure the girls are happy yeah
we're really proud proud of the
milestones but more importantly as how
they how they handled it you know I mean
it's one thing to become famous there's
a lot of people that get
variety of influencers but I think
they're testament of how to handle it
properly both of the great job that's
where as parents were the most proud
yeah I think you've hit the nail on the
head I mean they both you guys both seem
to have really good heads on your
shoulders and Charlie I know that you've
opened up a little bit about social
media and bullying and I would imagine
during a time like this it's really easy
to read the comments even more so how
has that been for you and for you Dixie
to kind of navigate the commenters and
the people who have something to say
whether it be positive or negative I
mean no matter when it is or who it is
or how many people like it hurts because
at the same time you're interacting with
people that really love and support you
there's always like those negative
comments mixed in so it's hard to not
see them but I mean I think I'm trying
my best to not look at them as much and
not it's hard because I know I do it and
it's really really hard not to it some
people are just a little story the
comments there's people in there that
really do Google like watching my videos
and a joy me posting and I want to be
able to give back to them and like their
comments from five so it's it's hard but
I'm I'm working on it now's a good time
to focus on myself and making sure and
happy and healthy and as well as
everyone else that's more important than
feeding into the negative comments
absolutely I would agree Dixie do you
want to add to that at all I feel like
it doesn't bother me I'm not going to
say at all but just thinking about it
like when someone leaves a negative
comment like okay well they don't know
who I am as a person so they don't have
full opinion on me because even people
like who like leave to pay on all of our
stuff every time like we'll see he
repeated people it's like well they
don't know who you are
just because they don't like you doesn't
mean you're not you are what they're
saying
right I do want to kind of transition a
bit because Charlie I know that you kind
of teased a tour and amid everything
that's happening
how are your guys's projects being
affected by everything going on right
now so we took all that stuff because
now is more of the time fee and being
able to just whatever they can do to
help themselves and their families and
the people that are working day and
night trying to help us with all the
possible entrance not more important to
us
I know then putting on a tour it's
obviously very important to us to meet
our fans but so really put a big pause
on that a hundred percent just so we can
focus on doing things to help everyone
get better before they do that again
yeah and now you have more time to make
family tic TOCs right yeah I do also
have to ask you you've been making
content with one of my favorite actors
on stranger things neat so we met
tik-tok a long time ago he was super
super sweet to me when I met him and it
was so much fun dancing this handed and
him teaching me acting so it's just fun
he just made up a dance that went very
viral so I was really cool to see like
that feels like I hang out with Charlie
for one day super funny to see yeah I
know I love that you said he's teaching
you acting so is acting something that
you would like to pursue so I took where
the raw voice acting I did my first
voice acting for an indie movie so
that's more in the works that's right
now nothing really with you just yet but
I'd love to get into it I mean I did
have a private session with for the
stars from stranger things acting lesson
so super cool but I mean in my YouTube
video you can see that was a little bit
more difficult for me but it was super
fun and I'd love to get into yeah could
we see you do more voice acting I feel
like we could get the whole family and
an animated much well I mean I would
love to I had so much fun doing it and
it was something that I really enjoyed
which is more than stuff that I like to
stick to stuff it's genuinely fun for me
so I would love to get more into that
and do as much as I can with what happen
I mean I feel like the sky is really the
limit for you guys you said that you're
maybe working on a reality show like
what about a fashion line Beauty line I
think people are very invested in your
guys's style which is a weird thing to
be talking about at a time like this but
also it kind of takes our mind off
things
yeah I mean you would love to see how
many opportunities we can really look at
like and see how much he can do and how
much you enjoy and how much is fun for
us as a family and so we would love to
yeah once again just like try as
anything does he can do you guys have a
message to the fans right now that you
want to relay even if it's especially
importance of staying home and bringing
it back to the distance dance I think
what you know we're well aware of how
this is affecting people there's a lot
of sick people out there there's a lot
of people and that's in in in our minds
every day
and but there has been some positivity
that's come out of this or it's brought
families a bit closer together
even our family which is very close
prior to this we're spending a lot of
quality time together so there's a
silver lining
in this tragedy and that's what we're
realizing I love that you sent up that
because so many people have said this
has made them feel more present in their
lives and you sort of touched on how
it's making your family closer Dixie and
Charlie do you guys feel like that - do
you feel like you're bonding more with
your parents yeah definitely
really even sick of each other yeah
Charlie you're 15 in terms of getting
your driver's license is that something
I could that could happen once the
stay-at-home orders lifts have you
thought about how you're gonna celebrate
if we're all still at home we hear about
that every day you might be celebrating
a sweet 16 on the quarantine so yeah
okay we want to do a little rapid fire
with you guys if you don't mind your go
to quarantine snacks peanut butter
cookies like that you're like coffee and
they're like pretzels honey what are you
guys binging and streaming right now to
pass the time
Grey's Anatomy Grey's Anatomy - oh you
know the finale meet great we watch on
Netflix I've been watching it live yeah
yeah okay tiger cave we all watch do you
think Carol Baskin did it or what okay
you obviously take talked with JLo but
is there another dream collab that you
would love a celebrity that you'd love
to work with on tick tock make it take
so there was two people and one of those
dreams is that I'm so thankful for that
but another one was Lady gaga I'd be
printed
you're so palliative and I love her so
much I would love to get you from one
day have you guys ever like virtually
been in touch does she know that you're
a fan of hers I feel like she probably
watches your tic TOCs that would be epic
how do we make this happen
what are your guys's current limp in
outfits is it jeans are you normally in
sweats we are in pajamas a little bit
all ready every day because I just feel
like it makes me feel a little bit like
we have a normal life so I put jeans on
and a little bit of makeup I barely
[Music]